et on reste en politique avec les
élections législatives qui approche les
yvelinois sont appelés aux urnes pour
élire leurs représentants de leur
circonscription à l'assemblée nationale
ça se passera les 12 et 19 juin à la
rédaction de tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir
plus clair nous faisons le point sur les
enjeux du scrutin à venir dans les
yvelines focus aujourd'hui sur la
septième à circonscription mathilde de
franck où vous êtes avec nous bonsoir ça
alors quelles sont les communes
concernées déjà alors cette
circonscription justin l elle est située
au nord du département elle regroupe les
villes comme chanteloup-les-vignes
conflans sainte honorine triel sur seine
ou encore andresy et vernouillet cela
représente 150 mille yvelinois environ 7
7e circonscription penche plutôt vers le
centre doit de plus plusieurs années en
effet depuis 2010 est c'est la députée
michèle de vaucouleurs membre du modem
qui la dirige cependant cette dernière
ne se représente pas elle laisse sa
place à nadia et l'ancien logo google
est là à l'avenir parfois juste avant le
nadia et était député pour la 11e
circonscription attrape sa ville de
naissance cette dernière fait
aujourd'hui campagne dans la 7e
circonscription pour ensemble la
nouvelle confédération issus de trois
partis politiques pour la république en
marche alors est-ce qu'elle marche en
terrain conquis sans faire de mauvais
jeu de mots oui et non car si la grande
majorité des communes a voté pour
emmanuel macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle
les villes comme chanteloup ou melon ont
préféré donner leur voix à jean luc
mélenchon
c'est donc dans ces villes que nadia et
devra essayer de convaincre les
habitants et de regagner leur confiance
et donc parmi d autres candidats qui on
retrouve finalement et bien huit
candidats au total se disputent cette 7e
circonscription justin il ya une parité
exemplaire puisque ces quatre femmes
contre quatre hommes pour la gauche
c'est michel christophoul qui
représentera la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et solidaire alias lannux
seul membre du parti socialiste désigné
sur les douze circonscription des
yvelines elle pourrait faire basculer la
septième à gauche en s'appuyant sur les
votes acquis par la france dans soumises
notamment dans les communes de meulan et
de chanteloup les vignes pour la droite
c'est le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent bros
qui se porte candidat nombre des
républicains ce dernier avait été éludée
le premier tour des municipales dans sa
ville cet avocat bien connu dans la 7e
circonscription pourrait également se
voir propulser à l'assemblée nationale
du côté de l'extrême droite emmanuel
fortin sera la candidate pour le
rassemblement national et christelle
tizié gens de reconquête parmi les
autres candidats frédéric janvier sans
étiquette politique son programme est
constitué d'idées venant de droite comme
de gauche le conseiller municipal
d'opposition de conflans sainte honorine
ali kaya repart pour une troisième fois
tout sous la bannière de lutte ouvrière
part dont pierre plancoulaine fait
campagne pour le parti animalistes et
remy vincent pour le parti pirate
parfait merci beaucoup matip de franck
ou d'avoir été avec le journaliste pour
tv 78